[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen alles
Wichtige vom Sport das erfahren Sie von
Norbert Lehmann einen schönen guten
Abend auch von mir wie soll es laufen
mit dem Einbau klimafreundlicher Heizung
eines unserer Themen
ein Gesetz und viele Fragen der
Bundesrat debattiert über die
heizungspläne und spart nicht mit Kritik
ein Standort und viel Widerstand auf
Rügen bringt ein geplantes lng-terminal
die Insulaner auf die Barrikaden
eine Auszeichnung und viele Bewerber in
diesen Minuten wird in Berlin der
Deutsche Filmpreis vergeben
[Musik]
es soll klimafreundlicher geheizt werden
heute im Bundesrat waren die
ministerpräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
aber alles andere als begeistert von den
Plänen der Regierung dazu
der Gesetzentwurf sieht im Kern vor dass
ab 2024 jede neu eingebaute Heizung
zumindestens 65 Prozent mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben wird bestehende
Anlagen dürfen weiterlaufen und auch
repariert werden über 80-jährige der ein
Haus besitzen sind von den Regelungen
ausgenommen die Kritik an den Plänen hat
jetzt Patricia wiedermeier für Sie
Heizungsbauer Gerhard hadrath aus
Rosenheim kann sich zurzeit nicht retten
vor Aufträgen allerdings soll er nicht
Wärmepumpen einbauen sondern die Kunden
wollen neue Gas- oder Ölheizungen die
Unsicherheit sei riesig das geplante
Gesetz ab 2024 umzusetzen unmöglich die
engen Zeitfenster sind viel zu ihnen
gesetzt in der Zeit kommt es nicht
funktionieren es scheiter definitiv an
die Manpower und natürlich an der
Verfügbarkeit das enge Zeitfenster nur
ein Kritikpunkt von vielen heute im
Bundesrat wo das geplante Gesetz beraten
wurde ich halte es für klug jetzt mal
den Menschen auch ein Stückchen Zeit zu
lassen solche im Einzelfall ja
schwerwiegenden und teuren
Entscheidungen gut vorzubereiten mehr
Klarheit fordern alle Länder hinzu
kommen etliche Änderungswünsche der
Zeitpunkt ist in Kraft Tretens soll
verschoben werden auf 20 27 fand jedoch
keine Mehrheit ab dem gesetzlichen
Rentenalter soll keiner mehr gezwungen
werden Heizung auszutauschen Klarheit
sie über die Höhe der Förderung und
technologieoffenheit der Klimaschutz
muss praktisch lösbar sein es muss
machbar sein und es muss finanziell auch
realisierbar sein nicht jeder der ein
Haus hat ist damit automatisch Reich der
Wirtschaftsminister verteidigt sein
Gesetzesvorhaben nach 18 Jahren rentiere
sich der Einbau einer Wärmepumpe ist
also jetzt schon ohne Förderung über die
Dauer des Lebens attraktiver finanziell
attraktiver nicht in fossile Heizung zu
investieren mit Förderung die ihr bis zu
50% beträgt wird der Break Even Point
deutlich früher erreicht werden der
Bundesrat hat hier kein Einspruchsrecht
es bleibt jetzt Sache des Bundestages ob
und wenn ja Änderungswünsche übernommen
werden
und wie sieht es aus wird auf die
Änderungswünsche eingegangen oder ist
das jetzt alles schon eine Stein
gemeißelt also man hört einen Satz hier
in Berlin dieser Tage sehr oft und das
ist ein Zitat von Peter Struck dem
ehemaligen
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzenden der hat mal
gesagt kein Gesetz geht so in den
Bundestag kommt so aus dem Bundestag
raus wie es reingegangen ist und das
gilt ganz besonders für dieses Gesetz wo
vieles umstritten ist da arbeitet der
Bundestag jetzt dran aus allen Parteien
kommen Kritik und Nachfragen auch aus
den Regierungsparteien und der Bundesrat
der sich heute geäußert hat hat da Zeug
zwar kein Mitsprache recht aber die
Stimme der Länder haben natürlich im
Chor der Stimmen großes Gewicht weil sie
eben auch die Stimmung aus den Ländern
und von den Menschen mit transportieren
und dürften auch einen Einfluss haben
auf die Entscheidungen und auf die
Änderungen die da vorgenommen werden die
ampelparteien haben sich vorgenommen
dieses Gesetz bis zur Sommerpause durch
den Bundestag zu bringen das heißt wir
werden spätestens Ende Juni Anfang Juli
wissen welche Änderungen vorgenommen
werden soll und auch ab wann das Gesetz
gelten soll vielen Dank für deine
Energie
und auch wenn alternative Energien die
Zukunft sind in der Gegenwart braucht
Deutschland immer noch Erdgas und es in
seiner flüssigen Form importieren zu
können sind lng-terminist notwendig
bislang sind solche terminals in
Wilhelmshaven Brunsbüttel und
lubminenbetrieb bis Ende des Jahres
kommen ein weiteres in Wilhelmshaven und
einzelnen Stade hinzu als zusätzlichen
Standort plant der Bund Mukran auf Rügen
nach heftiger Kritik reiste
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck auf die Insel
Bernd moselbach und Susanne Seidel
Ortstermin in Mukran für
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck der
ideale Standort für lng-terminals
zurzeit nutzen den Hafen vor allem
Faehren und Frachter es ist sein zweiter
Besuch auf Rügen innerhalb weniger
Wochen die Zeit drängt die Anlagen
sollen noch in diesem Jahr ans Netz
gehen ein Terminal soll in Mukran
komplett neu gebaut werden dazu eine
Pipeline zum Hafen von Lubmin wo das Gas
ins europäische Netz eingespeist wird
das lng-terminal das bisher im
lubminerhafen liegt soll nach Mukran
verlegt werden das Ziel ist zum Winter
hin Leitung verlegt zu haben und dann
alles rausgesetzt das ist
genehmigungsfähig dann noch vom Hafen
aus die Gasversorgung für den Osten
Deutschlands oder für Deutschland dann
auch insgesamt bereitstellen zu können
die Zustimmung des Landes steht noch aus
vor allem der Umweltminister ist
skeptisch wir werden da sehr genau
prüfen und unsere genehmungsbehörden
sind dann in der bis heute liegen keine
entscheidungsreifen Unterlagen vor der
Tourismus rückenswichtigste Branche
fürchtet Einbußen Gemeinden haben
Bürgerbegehren angekündigt
Umweltorganisationen sehen die Natur auf
und vor der Insel in Gefahr da werden
wir alle politischen und auch
juristischen Schritte einleiten die es
dann möglich machen für uns als
Umweltverband dieses lng-terminal und
auch alle weiteren in Deutschland
aufzuhalten der Fahrplan der
Bundesregierung ist ehrgeizig das
Kabinett soll noch im Mai entscheiden
der Bundestag noch vor der Sommerpause
um unabhängiger zu werden von Importen
im Bereich Elektromobilität wohl
Deutschland um die Ansiedlung von
batteriezellfabriken nachdem die
schwedische Firma Nord wollte ein
Engagement zwischenzeitlich in Frage
gestellt hatte will sie nun doch eine
solche Fabrik im
schleswig-holsteinischen Heide bauen den
Ausschlag gab das nordwold umfangreiche
Staatshilfen zugesagt worden wenn das
die EU genehmigt könnten 2026 die ersten
Batteriezellen ausgeliefert werden
das Gründungsjubiläum eines anderen
Staates ist normalerweise kein Grund für
eine Bundestagsdebatte bei Israel ist
das wegen der nationalsozialistischen
Vergangenheit Deutschlands anders und so
haben die Abgeordneten an den Tag vor 75
Jahren erinnert an dem Israel seine
Unabhängigkeit erklärte
die Grundstein für das
deutsch-israelische Verhältnis legten
der erste israelische Premierminister
David Ben Gurion und Konrad Adenauer
seitdem pflegen beide Länder enge
Beziehungen aus Berlin berichtet Butter
Spiekermann
seine Exzellenz Ron prosor auf der
Ehrentribüne der israelische Botschafter
neben Bundespräsident Steinmeier das
Parlament gratuliert zur Staatsgründung
vor 75 Jahren nach Nazi Terror und dem
Mord an den Juden Europas habe Israel
Deutschland die Hand gereicht
unsere historische Verantwortung die
Existenz und die Sicherheit des Staates
Israel zu stützen dafür haben wir uns
unverbrüchlich verpflichtet durch die
jüngste Gewalt Eskalation sei die
Sicherheit Israels bedroht
israel hat jedes Recht sich zu
verteidigen und die aktuellen Angriffe
sind das Schärfste zu verurteilen eine
zwei staatenlösung sei weit entfernt mit
Blick auf die israelische Innenpolitik
würdigen viel im Bundestag die Proteste
der Zivilgesellschaft gegen die
Regierung netanjau das zeigt uns Israel
ist die lebendige liberale Demokratie im
Nahen Osten meine Damen und Herren
unerträglich sei dass der Antisemitismus
in Deutschland wieder grassiere
[Applaus]
noch immer werden Jüdinnen und Juden in
Deutschland wegen ihrer Herkunft und
wegen ihres Glaubens diffamiert und
bedroht ich hoffe ich kann für die sehr
große Mehrheit hier im Deutschen
Bundestag sagen dieses darf in
Deutschland nie wieder egal aus welcher
Richtung Platz bekommen
sorgenvolle Blicke von der Ehrentribüne
der Präsident und der Botschafter ein
Jubiläum zwischen großer
Nachdenklichkeit aber auch Zuversicht
schauen wenn die Ukraine denn da tut
sich offenbar was an der Front rund um
die seit Monaten heftig umkämpfte Stadt
bachmut im Osten des Landes
präsidente bestätigte Geländegewinne der
Armee passend dazu veröffentlichte das
Militär diese Bilder
ukrainische Einheiten Rücken offenbar
bei Mahmut vor Moskau meldet das
russische Einheiten verlegt würden der
Chef der Söldnergruppe Wagner
wer nach Dänemark reist oder pendelt
kann seit heute aufatmen denn die
Grenzkontrollen sind gelockert worden
das heißt an den 13 Übergängen muss der
Ausweis von nun an seltener gezeigt
werden die Kontrollen an den Grenzen
wurden Anfang 2016 eingeführt im Zuge
der flüchtlingskrise
gestern nach der Explosion in einem
Hochhaus in Ratingen war noch vieles
unklar inzwischen weiß die Polizei die
Einsatzkräfte wurden von dem 57-Jährigen
Bewohner gezielt mit einer brennenden
Flüssigkeit angegriffen gegen den
Verdächtigen des haftbefehler lassen
worden wegen versuchten Mordes in neuen
Fällen mehr von Thomas münden
es war eine geplante Tat gegen die sich
gestern Nachmittag in Ratingen die
Polizei mit einem sek-einsatz
verteidigen musste acht schwer verletzte
Helfer davon fünf im künstlichen Koma
der Tatverdächtige ein 57-jähriger
schleuderte gezielt eine entzündete
Flüssigkeit auf Polizisten und
Feuerwehrleute sie flüchteten brennend
aus dem Haus ich glaube es war geplant
in dieser Art und Weise gegen
öffentliche Dienste die gegebenenfalls
Mann sein Wirkungsbereich eindringen so
wie er es wahrscheinlich vermuten wird
und damit eben auch gegen Rettungskräfte
Polizei ich glaube dass das egal war
aber der andere war sicherlich gezielt
die Staatsanwaltschaft beschuldigt den
Mann des mindestens neunfachen
Mordversuche ist der vermeintliche Täter
der nur leicht verletzt wurde
verzichtete auf einen Rechtsbeistand die
Feuerwehr war zu einer Wohnungsöffnung
mit hilfloser Person gerufen worden die
Kollegen können sich nicht vorstellen
dass so ein Routine Einsatz der also
sage ich mal überhaupt nichts
Ungewöhnliches ist für uns sondern in
der Woche 20 mal anfällt so endet mit
einer solchen Aggressivität mit seiner
solchen Brutalität in einer anderen
Wohnung im gleichen Haus fand die
Polizei noch einen weiteren Toten ob es
einen Zusammenhang zu der Tat im
Dachgeschoss gibt es unklar der
Tatverdächtige gehörte nach ersten
Erkenntnissen der Ermittler eventuell
zur präpaszene und hatte auch Waffen in
seinem Keller er schweigt zu allen
Vorwürfen
am Sonntag wird in Bremen die
Bürgerschaft gewählt das Landesparlament
die SPD hofft wie schon in den letzten
77 Jahren den Bürgermeister zu stellen
laut neuesten ZDF Politbarometer kommt
die CDU auf 26% der Stimmen die SPD auf
29 grüne 13 Prozent die Linke 11 die FDP
würde mit sechs Prozent in die
Bürgerschaft einziehen BÜRGER IN WUT
eine rechtspopulistische Regionalpartei
liegt bei 10 Prozent die Wahllisten der
AFD sind nicht zugelassen da noch rund
40 Prozent der Wahlberechtigten
unentschlossen sind wird bis zur letzten
Minute weiter gekämpft kein Niklas
der Bremer Bürgermeister mag es den Ton
anzugeben
spd-abschlussveranstaltung mit
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz im ZDF
Politbarometer wollen 60% Andreas
bovenschulte als Regierungschef und er
spielt diese Karte voll aus wir haben
das gesamte Land im Blick und wir sagen
es braucht ein starken Bürgermeister mit
einer starken Partei im Rücken damit wir
diesen politischen Führungsanspruch
verwirklichen können Landwirt und CDU
Spitzenkandidat Frank Imhoff würde gern
die Politik in Bremen neu anschieben 23%
wollen ihn als Regierungschef er kann
sich vorstellen mit der SPD
zusammenzukommen wenn auch nicht um
jeden Preis ich habe keine Lust mehr
mich ein Problem einzurichten sondern
ich möchte gerne Probleme gelöst haben
und das wird in ein Koalitionsvertrag zu
schreiben sein und wenn das mit der SPD
möglich ist
dann ja okay die grüne Spitzenkandidatin
Maike Schäfer arbeitet trotz Verlusten
am Fortbestand des bestehenden
linksbündnisses ich gebe nicht auf ich
bin kämpferisch und ja ich gehe davon
aus dass es unser Ziel dass wir auch
weiter mit regieren werden die
Spitzenkandidatin der Linken Christina
Vogt bekam als Wirtschaftssenatorin viel
Anerkennung und spricht sich ebenfalls
für die Fortsetzung von rot grün rot aus
die Liberalen mit Spitzenkandidat Tore
Scheck wollen mit den Themen innere
Sicherheit und eine autofreundlichen
Verkehrspolitik Punkten die
Wählervereinigung BÜRGER IN WUT
profitiert offenbar mit deutlichen
Stimmen gewinnen davon dass die AFD
aufgrund von antragsfehlern zur Wahl
nicht zugelassen wurde über die
Zusammensetzung der Bremischen
Bürgerschaft entscheiden die Wählerinnen
und Wähler an diesem Sonntag
auch in der Türkei wird am Sonntag
abgestimmt es sind präsidentschafts- und
Parlamentswahlen und es ist spannend wie
lange nicht denn die Opposition hat sich
zu einem Bündnis zusammengerauft und
Präsident Erdogan zu besiegen es wird
wohl sehr knapp werden zum
Wahlkampfabschluss
wie in der Moschee nach Geschlechtern
getrennt strenggläubige Unterstützer
jubeln ihrem Präsidenten zu im Schluss
Sport seines Wahlkampf heute in Istanbul
hofft Erdogan darauf dass sie auch
diesmal der konservativ religiöse Teil
seines Volkes zum Sieg tragen wird
am Sonntag werdet ihr denen eine solch
heftige Lektion erteilen dass sie sich
endlich in den Ruhestand zurückziehen
müssen
gemeint ist sein Herausforderer Kemal
Kilic derolu Chef der kemalistisch
sozialdemokratischen CHP er führt ein
Bündnis von sechs Oppositionsparteien an
die Umfragen kurz vor der Wahl sehen
kilica Rollo mit knapp im vorsprungform
wir werden ein autoritäres Regime mit
demokratischen Mitteln verändern
verspricht der UNO und wir werden der
ganzen Welt damit ein gutes Beispiel
sein
gestern hatte sich mit morem inje ein
mitbewerbe ums Präsidentenamt aus dem
Rennen zurückgezogen das könnte dem
Oppositionsbündnis zu gutute kommen bei
dieser Wahl geht es um die eine große
Entscheidung bleibt Erdogan oder muss er
gehen die Chancen der Oppositionen sind
gut der amtierende Präsident aber noch
lange nicht geschlagen die Frage ist ob
die unterlegene Partei das Ergebnis
anerkennen oder anfechten wird ob es
ruhig bleibt auf den Straßen nach dieser
Schicksalswahl für die Türkei
viele Beobachter erwarten dass diese
Wahl erst nach einer Stichwahl in zwei
Wochen entschieden werden könnte
und zur Wahl in der Türkei möchten wir
Ihnen unser ZDF heute live empfehlen wir
sprechen unter anderem mit einer
Journalistin die in türkische Haft saß
um 19.30 in unserer ZDF heute App dort
finden Sie auch weitere Infos und
Hintergründe insbesondere zu den Themen
die Wahl entscheidend sein dürften
und da ist sie die goldene Lola heißt
begehrtender Filmbranche die große Frage
ist wer ergattert sie heute Abend in
diesen Minuten geht die Verleihung des
Deutschen Filmpreises los in Berlin vor
großen Publikum Favorit mit den meisten
Nominierungen ist der Oskar prämierte
Anti-Kriegsfilm im Westen nichts Neues
wer noch ins Rennen geht und über das
Schaulaufen auf dem roten Teppich Nadja
nasser
wenn die Deutsche Filmakademie zur
lola-verleihung einlädt kommen sie alle
die Stars der Film- und Fernsehbranche
und natürlich die die sich Hoffnung auf
einen Preis machen im Westen nichts
Neues ist in zwölf Kategorien nominiert
an diesem Film kommt heute Abend wohl
keiner ganz vorbei
das weiß man nie ja also das ist ja sind
viele gute Filme nominiert viele
Kolleginnen da die einfach großartige
Filme machen und darauf freue ich mich
ach wir wollen einfach feiern das ist
anstrengend und aufregend und
überwältigend aber vor allem schön auch
Leonie bienisch gehört zu denen die
heute Abend besonders aufgeregt sind sie
geht als beste Hauptdarstellerinnen der
zdf-co-produktion das Lehrerzimmer ins
Rennen mit sieben Nominierungen gilt der
Film als mit Favorit ich bin jetzt
nervös ich glaube ich glaube ich freue
mich am meisten darauf wenn die
Verleihung vorbei ist und wir uns alle
ja bei einem ganz treffen können die
Ehrenpreis für sein Lebenswerk bekommt
regisseur Volker schlöndorf der
84-Jährige Oscar-Preisträger drehte
Filmklassiker wie die Blechtrommel und
prägt seit mehr als sechs Jahrzehnten
die deutsche Filmlandschaft
naja ein bisschen Aufregung gibt es
schon ja es ist doch ganz klar weil da
plötzlich 2000 Kollegen gegenüber sitzt
ja mit viel Geschichte zwischen uns oft
ja gute und schlechte das ist schon
bewegender Moment vor wenigen Minuten
hat die Verleihung begonnen
und wenn sie die Verleihung jetzt noch
live miterleben wollen können Sie das
auf zdf.de und wir machen jetzt weiter
mit Sport und zwar mit der Fußball
Europa League Norbert dann Leverkusen
der gestern Abend im Halbfinale
Niederlage einstellen ja knappes Ding
0:1 verloren in Rom gut gespielt gut
mitgehalten nein bitterer Abend für die
Bayer 11 aber die Italiener in der
zweiten Halbzeit ein Tick und ein Tor
besser trotzdem ist nächsten Donnerstag
im Rückspiel daheim noch alles drin
mehr Ballbesitz mehr Eckbälle und doch
geht Leverkusen als Verlierer vom Platz
U21 Nationalspieler Renato Bove erzielt
für die Römer 63 Minute das
entscheidende Torwart Radetzki kann den
Schuss von Tammy Abraham nur nach vorne
abwehren
Geschmack von mir von uns aber wir haben
schon auch gespürt dass wir diese
Mannschaft fahren können also
das beste
schlimmer sein können schlimm dagegen
der Mittelfußbruch von Robert Andrich
Saison aus für ihn wie für odilon mit
einer Muskelverletzung beiercoach ich
habe ja lonso muss ohne sie das
Rückspiel gegen seinen Ex-Trainer José
Mourinho gewinnen damit der Traum vom
ersten Leverkusener Titel seit 30 Jahren
weitergehen kann
[Applaus]
die Empfehlung des IOC russische und
belarussische Athleten unter neutraler
Flagge wieder an internationalen
Veranstaltungen teilnehmen zu lassen
stößt weiter auf Kritik heute haben sich
die deutschen sportministerinnen und
Minister einstimmig dagegen
ausgesprochen von der heute beginnenden
Eishockey WM in Finnland und Lettland
sind Russland und belarussia
ausgeschlossen gleich trifft Deutschland
auf den elfmeigen Weltmeister Schweden
der neue DHB Trainer Harold Kreis hat
sich einiges vorgenommen
das Ziel in Tampere ist klar formuliert
Viertelfinale und Olympia Qualifikation
dafür müsste Deutschland mindestens
vierter werden in einer Vorrundengruppe
mit acht Mannschaften trotz viele
Ausfälle hat Bundestrainer Kreis ein
defensiv starkes Team nominiert um
NHL-Star Verteidiger Moritz Seider der
rechtzeitig zu Turnier beginnt wurde
Jungs haben wirklich sehr gut gearbeitet
er hat gearbeitet das ist selber eine
Truppe die wasserreichen möchte hier
also da habe ich ein wirklich gutes
Gefühl hochrangige Gegner warten gleich
zu Beginn mit Schweden und Titel
Verteidiger Finnland
ja und die hat gerade das WM
Eröffnungsspiel gegen die USA mit 1 zu 4
verloren
willkommen zu einer Königin einer
Königin der ihre Untertan quasi
bedingungslos folgen in Berlin
Friedrichshain schwirrten mehrere
tausend Bienen durch die Luft und
folgten der Königin des Volkes in einen
Baum um es sich dort gemütlich zu machen
die rentende Idee kamen nicht von der
Feuerwehr sondern ein Imker mit langer
Leiter die Chefin einfangen ab in einen
neuen Bienenstock und einfach warten bis
alle anderen Folgen das passierte dann
sogar schneller als erwartet
mit schauen und Gewittern geht es morgen
in die nächste Runde mehr dazu gleich
beim Wetter von ostentelli das heute
journal können Sie um 22 Uhr sehen mit
Marietta Slomka schönen Freitagabend
noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter umgekehrte
Verhältnisse haben wir derzeit hier auf
unserer Wetterkarte nach Norden hin
haben wir hohenluftdruck und im Süden
tiefen diese Konstellation ist recht
stabil und hält sich noch eine Weile
deswegen gibt es auch im Alpenraum
weiterhin Regen und sogar Schnee aber
auch Richtung Balkan und nach Frankreich
hin und bei uns gibt's morgen shower und
Gewitter in der Nacht erst einmal wenige
Schauer im Norden da klar das auf und es
ist trocken und die Temperaturen sinken
auf vier Grad an den Alpen und elf Grad
ganz im Westen das ist die
Temperaturspanne und morgen dann vor
allem im Norden viel Sonne nach Osten in
einige harmlose Wolken ansonsten aber
Schauer und Gewitter die sich nach
Westen verlagern und auch ganz im Süden
an den Alpen hängen viele Wolken und
Blitz und Donner ist auch dabei mit
höchsten Temperaturen dort bis 14 Grad
aber schauen Sie nach Norden 22 bis 24
Grad hier Richtung Berlin an den Küsten
18 bis 21 Grad recht warm
die nächsten Tage das mit den schauen
und Gewittern setzt sich fort am Sonntag
nach Norden den trocken aber sonst
durchwachsen und am Montag geht es im
Grunde genommen so weiter damit ein
schöner Abend